wusstet ihr schon dass in den urknall
von zu hause aus sehen könnt und was
macht eigentlich ein riesiger alkohol
wolke im weltraum
hier kommen unglaubliche menschen die
euch zum mittelpunkt des gesprächs auf
der nächsten astrophysiker party machen
werden nummer eins
die größte fahne aller zeiten
nein es geht nicht um solche fahnen
sondern um solche hier aber in unserem
fall in der wissenschaft sehen die so
aus ungefähr 6500 lichtjahre von uns
entfernt befindet sich eine riesige
alkohol wolke und nein das ist nicht der
austragungsort des nächsten
intergalaktischen oktoberfest denn die
besteht aus methanol also bitte nicht
bewusst genießen sondern gar nicht
genießen
aber spaß beiseite das vorkommen von
alkohol also relativ simples molekül ist
im weltall eigentlich keine überraschung
aber dieser alkohol wolke zeigt uns
etwas sehr sehr spannendes und das
könnte eigentlich ein ganzes video
füllen deswegen hier jetzt mal das ganze
nur in kurzform 1 motor und zwar geht es
hier um mazur besser funktionieren nach
demselben prinzip wie laser aber während
ein laser sichtbares licht verstärkt
versteckt an mazur mikrowellenstrahlung
damit ein messer aber funktionieren kann
wollen das erst mal bestimmte
bedingungen zb methanol moleküle am
besten sehr sehr viele davon auf ganz
engem raum so dass protonen moleküle
quasi an strukturen so eine
kettenreaktion auslösen und dann wochen
natürlich auch noch eine energiequelle
die den ganzen prozess anstoß zum
beispiel proto sterne also sehr sehr
junge sterne die gerade erst an masse
gewinnen
und jetzt kommt unsere alkohol wolke in
sechs 1500 lichtjahren entfernung ins
spiel
hier herrschen die optimalen bedingungen
für einen astrophysikalischen
einerseits durch das ganze methanol auf
engem raum gleichzeitig funktioniert
diese wolke aber auch als so etwas wie
eine brutstätte für neue sterne also für
unsere benötigte energiequelle
ursprünglich hat man gedacht das messer
eine menschliche erfindung sind und
nicht natürlich auftreten
diese wolke beweist aber das gegenteil
und sie ist auch ein hinweis darauf dass
unsere naturgesetze nicht nur hier bei
uns auf der erde gelten sondern auch
ganz ganz weit draußen im universum
natürlich ist unsere alkohol wolke keine
zielgerichtete strahlungs emissionen wie
beim menschen gemachten mehr sein
sondern sie mehrzad so vor sich hin ist
ja auch ein naturphänomen okay weiter
geht's nummer zwei die erde hat nicht
die einzige ozeane in unserem
sonnensystem ein weiterer ozean wird oft
titan vermutet einem mond des saturn
radarmessungen einer sonde deuten
nämlich darauf hin dass unter der
eiskruste des titan ein ozean aus
flüssigem aber super salzigem wasser ist
das allein ist schon ziemlich
interessant aber es gibt eine
ungereimtheit denn titan ist fast
komplett von eis bedeckt und es
herrschen hier - 183 grad celsius
wie kann es also hier flüssiges wasser
geben die antwort ist eigentlich ganz
einfach frostschutzmittel also meinen
unsere sonne fliegen da nicht regelmäßig
hin und sprühen den ganzen mond ein
sondern es gibt auf dem titan einen
natürlichen frostschutz der ozean dort
soll zu zehn prozent aus ammoniak
bestehen was dem gefrierpunkt von wasser
senkt und auch bei diesen temperaturen
flüssiges wasser ermöglicht falls ihr
jetzt gerade einen interplanetaren surft
geplant dann solltet ihr euch beeilen
denn trotz anti freeze friert dieser
ozean geradezu übrigens gibt es auf
titan wahrscheinlich nicht den einzigen
weiteren ozean in unserem sonnensystem
noch einen könnte es in europa geben auf
europa also dem jupitermond europa
da schickt die esa bald eine sonde hinum
nach fremdem leben zu suchen schon 2022
soll es soweit sein
und jetzt mein kleines gedankenspiel
sollten wir das tatsächlich fremdes
leben finden und wir sollten den mond
kolonialen
dann würden europäer andere europäer
kolonialisieren
das wäre mal was neues nummer drei die
iss ist größer als du denkst zugegeben
dass die ice erst groß ist das wird
wahrscheinlich die wenigsten von euch
überraschen aber von hier unten auf der
erde vergisst man relativ schnell wie
sich tatsächlich die internationale
raumstation iss denn wir haben ja keine
referenz wenn wir sie sehen wir sehen
sie entweder auch vor dem schwarzen
weltall oder der erde beides ziemlich
groß und eine banane daneben verhalten
ist wahrscheinlich auch eine gute
referenz
aber keine sorge wir hier bei doktor
watson haben die fixen und begnadeten
vortragsart aller zeiten beschäftigt und
wir scheuen keine kosten oder mühen um
euch die iss auf die erde zu holen damit
ihr sie mit etwas vergleichen könnt was
ihr kennt zum beispiel den kölner dom
und das sieht wirklich krass aus
[Musik]
und damit wir unsere ganzen krassen vor
fix auch bezahlen können kommt jetzt
eine kurze werbung von unserem sponsor
blinkt ist wenn ihr absolut nicht genug
von weltall bekommen könnt dann kann ich
euch eine kurze geschichte der zeit von
stephen hawking empfehlen da geht es um
den urknall um schwarze löcher und um
das kleinste teilchen in unserem
universum ein wirklich tolles buch das
auch vor allem schön und einfach
verständlich geschrieben ist und mit
links könnt ihr dieses buch in nur 21
minuten lesen denn blinkt ist bricht
lange bücher auf das wesentliche
herunter und teilt die wichtigsten
aussagen der bücher in einzelne
sogenannte links auf es gibt über 3000
sachbücher im angebots gibt ratgeber
klassiker und bestseller aus über 25
kategorien wie wissenschaft
produktivität und psychologie jeden
monat kommen ungefähr 40 15 minütige
blinkx hinzu und wenn ihr doch mal
tiefer in ein buch einsteigen wollt dann
findet ihr inzwischen auch ganze
hörbücher auf blinkt ist im moment gibt
es eine aktion mit der die ganze 25
prozent auf ein jahres abo blinkt ist
premium sparen könnt dafür müsst ihr nur
aufblinken punkt de / doktor watson
gehen und ein abo abschließen und wenn
ihr euch jetzt immer noch nicht ganz so
sicher seid dann könnt ihr das komplette
angebot erst mal sieben tage lang
kostenlos testen und euch erst mal
anhören was der liebe stephen hawking zu
erzählen nummer vier
die fußabdrücke auf dem mond bleiben für
immer
was haben eigentlich astronauten der
apollo-missionen alles auf dem mond
hinterlassen
und ja tatsächlich eine ganze menge
sechs amerika flaggen drei golfbälle das
komplette lande module der
apollo-11-mission und tatsächlich auch
fußabdrücke nämlich alle fußabdrücke von
neil armstrong buzz aldrin und allen
anderen astronauten die auf dem mond
oben gelaufen sind und die werden dann
auch für eine ziemlich lange zeit
bleiben denn auf dem mond gibt es keine
atmosphäre also auch weder wind noch
wasser um die fußabdrücke weg zu wählen
oder wegzuspülen
aber nichts hält ewig das hat mir meine
oma immer gesagt und tatsächlich
schlagen auf der oberfläche des mondes
ständig ganz ganz kleine mikrometeoriten
sie liegen zwar jeder für sich genommen
weniger als ein gramm aber in der menge
und vor allem über den langen zeitraum
können sie die oberfläche des mondes
tatsächlich komplett verändern
wenn ihr also noch so lange es geht in
die fußstapfen von neil armstrong treten
volt wortwörtlich dann abonniert doch
den kanal denn in drei wochen laden wir
hier auf dem kanal ein video hoch in dem
wir euch zeigen wie man wirklich
astronaut wird und noch ein ganz großer
bonus verstärkt über astronauten das
wort astronaut leitet sich aus dem
altgriechischen astra für stern und dem
griechischen autos für sie klar ab
astronauten sind also wortwörtlich
sternen sekler ziemlich cool oder wie
jede mutter von zu hause aus sehen könnt
nein das ist kein scherz und auch kein
klick welt ihr könnt tatsächlich von zu
hause aus jetzt heute überreste des
urknalls sehen allerdings braucht ihr
dafür einen alten fernseher und
ausnahmsweise mal keinen empfang
klingt verwirrend lasst es mich erklären
auch wenn hier auf der erde einige dinge
anders sind als ein paar hundert
lichtjahre entfernt ist eines immer
gleich egal wo wir uns im universum
befinden
und zwar die hintergrundstrahlung oder
um genau zu sein der kosmischen
mikrowellenhintergrund nein nicht so
einer
ich meine so ein hier
das ist isotope strahlung im
mikrowellenbereich die das ganze
universum füllt entstanden ist das ganze
ungefähr 380 1000 jahre nach dem urknall
und gilt als ein beleg für die
urknalltheorie ok aber was hat das jetzt
mit alten fernsehern und keinem empfang
zu tun
strahlung können wir menschen nicht
sehen riechen oder schmecken aber geräte
können strahlung empfang zum beispiel
radios unsere smartphones oder eben alte
röhrenfernseher so einer nimmt den
allgegenwärtigen kosmischen
mikrowellenhintergrund auf und zeigten
uns praktischerweise auch noch an wenn
wir keinen sender ausgewählt haben
ja dieses rauschen zwischen den kanälen
dass ihr vielleicht noch aus ihrer
kindheit kennt ist tatsächlich zum teil
das nachglühen des urknalls direkter
space max das mega cool aber es war
automatisch der mitte kommt der nächste
party wenn partys dingwerth und dass man
gerade machen kann
aber kann man nicht deswegen müsst ihr
wohl einfach auf die nächste folge von
strauß aki warten denn das ist ein neues
format das ist hier gerade ausprobieren
schreibt uns gerne mal in die kommentare
ob ihr dieses video hier cool findet ob
wir noch mehr davon sehen wollt was wir
verbessern können welche space fakten
ihr vielleicht habt und alles weitere
was mich noch so einfällt
vielen dank fürs zuschauen und bleibt
neugierig
[Musik]